[Music]
on'y stands before a large golden scale
where the jackal-headed God Anubis is
weighing his heart against a pure
ostrich feather ani was a real person
ascribed from the Egyptian city of
Thebes who lived in the 13th century BCE
and depicted here is a scene from his
book of the Dead a 78 foot papyrus
scroll designed to help him attain
immortality such funerary texts were
originally written only for pharaohs but
with time the Egyptians came to believe
regular people could also reach the
afterlife if they succeeded in the
passage Anees epic journey begins with
his death his body is mummified by a
team of priests who remove every organ
except the heart the seat of emotion
memory and intelligence
it's then stuffed with a salt called
Natron and wrapped in a resin soaked
linen in addition the wrappings are
woven with charms for protection and
topped with a heart scarab amulet that
will prove important later on the goal
of the two-month process is to preserve
Ana's body as an ideal form with which
his spirit can eventually reunite but
first that spirit must pass through the
Duat or underworld this is a realm of
vast caverns lakes of fire and magical
gates all guarded by fearsome beasts
snakes crocodiles and half-human
monstrosity with names like he who
dances in blood to make things worse a
pep the serpent god of destruction lurks
in the shadows waiting to swallow
Anees soul fortunately Ani is prepared
with the magic contained within his Book
of the Dead like other Egyptians who
could afford it
ani customised his scroll to include the
particular spells prayers and codes he
thought his spirit might need
equipped with this arsenal our hero
traverses the obstacles repels the
monsters attacks and stealthily avoids a
pet to reach the Hall of Maat
goddess of truth and justice here
ani faces his final challenge he is
judged by 42 Assessor gods who must be
convinced that he has lived a righteous
life Ani approaches each one addressing
them by name and declaring a sin he has
not committed
among these negative confessions or
declarations of innocence he proclaims
that he has not made anyone cry is not
an eavesdropper and has not polluted the
water but did Ani really live such a
perfect life not quite but that's where
the heart scarab amulet comes in it's
inscribed with the words do not stand as
a witness against me precisely so unnies
heart doesn't betray him by recalling
the time he listened to his neighbor's
fight or washed his feet in the Nile
now it's Anees moment of truth the
weighing of the heart if his heart is
heavier than the feather weighed down by
Ana's wrongdoings
it'll be devoured by the monstrous Ummat
part crocodile part leopard part
hippopotamus and Ani will cease to exist
forever but Ani is in luck
his heart is judged pure raha the Sun
God takes him to Osiris god of the
underworld who gives him final approval
to enter the afterlife in the endless
and lush field of reeds Ani meets his
deceased parents here there is no
sadness pain or anger but there is work
to be done like everyone else Ani must
cultivate a plot of land which he does
with the help of a Shakti doll that had
been placed in his tomb
today the papyrus of ani resides in the
British Museum where it has been since
1888 only Ani if anyone knows what
really happened after his death but
thanks to his book of the dead we can
imagine him happily tending his crops
for all eternity
[Music]